this is a production of cornell
university
great thank you very much andy and thank
you to sips for
hosting this discussion and thanks to
rebecca for
for joining me in this presentation
we'll we'll do this as a tag team where
i will
present first and then pass off to
rebecca as andy mentioned
a large group of us i'll introduce the
group in just a moment
produced an expert panel report with one
of those just
melissa titles that rolls right off the
tongue socio-technical innovation
bundles
for agri-food systems transformation
deep breath so the cover is there this
is
available on the nature website it was
the
2020 expert panel of the journal nature
sustainability
and the exercise was coordinated and
financed by the atkinson center so
our thanks to both the editorial team at
nature sustainability
and especially to the atkinson center
team so that
the core of the report was built
out of a dialogue that lasted for
basically a year
early and fall a number of us started
pulling together some background
materials but we kicked off the expert
panel in december 2019
with a panel meeting down on the
roosevelt island
campus of cornell tech and from then we
began deliberation
as a group depicted around the edges
of this slide that culminated in the
2020 december 2020 release of the report
so it was
just under a year from start to finish
which in the midst of pandemic
i thought was actually rather good that
we managed to pull this off
on schedule in spite of the massive
disruptions caused that we couldn't for
example come together in fall
to to work on the report together as
planned and that we obviously had to
adjust content to the report to address
issues raised by the pandemic
but the defining feature of this expert
panel i think was the diversity of its
participants as andy alluded to
as you can see around with the pictures
around the border here
i mean considerable diversity in in
terms of of gender
and race and ethnicity uh but also
diversity in terms of of where people
reside
the geography of their interests
diversity in terms of the organizations
their affiliations we had donor
organizations like
the rockefeller foundation or the
african development bank we had
venture capital we had large-scale
institutional investment houses
we had big companies like walmart or
nestle
or pepsi we had ngos like the nature
conservancy and oxfam
lots of academics from around the world
and
quite different disciplines i'm an
economist
rebecca is a plant pathologist plant
breeder
we had people from the environmental
sciences the agricultural sciences the
social sciences even law so
this was a real meeting of the minds in
many ways and that's
i think the part that gives it a little
bit of heft
is this isn't a narrow perspective this
is what a very
active well-regarded group of people
could find common ground on
and among the key things that really
need emphasize and
at some level i can't do justice to a
very long report
i encourage people to download it and
read it or at least read the the summary
that is also available but this really
starts from
the need to keep in mind two different
key facts
that often get ignored by
one camp or another in arguments around
food systems transformation the first is
that
agri-food systems innovations of our
lifetime
over the last 50 some years have had
absolutely
huge positive impacts on human
well-being so the graphic that i show
here is from the report just showing the
change in the
the percentage of undernourished
populations around the world
in in the red line but perhaps most
importantly
showing the blue mass which is the
population
the human population that gets adequate
dietary energy
any given day net population has been
growing by 90 million people a year
10 000 people per hour so while we
commonly will focus on the red line and
how
the the prevalence of undernourishment
has largely stalled indeed it's
it's begun to increase again in recent
years and surely has increased during
the pandemic
perhaps the most remarkable and
unremarked upon
feature of global agri-food systems is
its
extraordinary ability to expand the
reach of
people who are getting adequate dietary
energy
and the reason why that is important is
roll back
50 60 70 years in 1968
paul ehrlich's the population bomb
volume was a
raging popular success people were
really concerned
that we were heading for a malthusian
crash
that people were going to begin starving
on mass
because the world simply couldn't
produce enough food to meet the basic
dietary
energy intake requirements of a rapidly
growing human population
the world designed agri-food systems
and agri-food research systems in
particular
to address what it perceived at that
time as the big challenge
growing human populations that would not
get enough energy to survive and we'd
have mass famine
clearly the world's agri-food systems
have succeeded in meeting that challenge
they were designed largely around that
the cgir's first
chairman famously talked about the
purpose of the cgir
was to grow the pile of rice available
to foods
food short consumers well that has
succeeded so it's important to embrace
that fact it's equally important to
embrace the fact that
while the world's agri-food systems have
succeeded in meeting the objective of
providing adequate dietary energy
for a growing human population they have
failed in other
very important dimensions there have
been un
unsustainable spillover effects on
climate and the environment
they're important social justice
considerations growing inequity in the
system
with the extreme risk to which many
farmers and farm workers
impose farm gate workers in places like
slaughterhouses
are exposed to their important public
health and nutrition concerns around
the the food basket that is being
produced processed
distributed and consumed and so we must
keep in mind both the successes and the
challenges of the system
that we must embrace the possibility of
success through innovation as was
ignited 60 plus years ago
indeed we must accelerate innovation but
we have to change the objectives
and that gets us to key conclusions the
report
of the report of the expert panel so the
first is
we started by let's define the agri-food
system and i emphasize agri-food
as a somewhat clunky modifier because
the system begins with the production of
agricultural commodities largely but not
exclusively on farms or in fisheries
and those agricultural commodities get
transformed
into the foods we consume today in a
paper now forthcoming in nature food 73
percent
of consumer food expenditures worldwide
represent value edition post farm gate
value addition that happens
in processors in manufacturers in
wholesalers retailers restaurants
most of the value of the food we consume
does not originate in the farm it
originates post-farm so we have to keep
in mind
that there's food on the end and there's
agricultural
practices at the beginning hence the
agri-food system
language that we use to represent that
there's a very complex web of actors
and of processes both biotic and abiotic
processes
as we think through food systems there
are really four key features that the
the expert panel emphasized throughout
this report
the first is it is a system but it is
not
a system that is lends itself to
optimization there is no controller of
the system
rather it is a system of billions
of people who are individually making
production consumption
distribution decisions every day
and that means that if you can't
optimize a system
you have to do what we economists call
mechanism design
you have to design the rules of
engagement the institutions of the
system
to induce people to make behaviors that
are mutually reinforcing
and generate favorable outcomes that we
expect will generate favorable outcomes
you can't just change pull a lever and
get everybody to do
what you want so human agency is really
the
key defining feature of all of this that
humans are the source of most of the
problems in agri-food systems
we are also the prospective source of
solutions
but inducing people to do the right
things far more often than not
is going to be the key to agri-food
system transformation
the second crucial thing that one has to
keep in mind is the heterogeneity of
agri-food systems there are no
one-size-fits-all solutions
even within a given location what's
right for one sub-population can differ
from
what's going to work best for another
i'll come to examples of that in just a
couple of slides
the third core point we wanted to make
about agri-food systems
is that spillover effects are pervasive
and hence you need portfolio approaches
what we refer to as socio-technical
bundles
representing that they're going to be
bundles of technical solutions
based in bench science as well as social
solutions
based partly on social science but much
on cultural issues and economic
policy and on the political economy of
systems
spillover effects are pervasive in the
sense that interventions that intend to
achieve one goal
invariably affect multiple goals at a
time
as part of this project a group of us
produced a paper that published in the
lancet planetary health earlier this
year
demonstrating how every single
innovation we could identify
targeted to achieving an sdg
related to the food system so for
example improvement in germplasm
intended to help reduce hunger
consistent with sustainable development
goal two that has spillover
effects on other sdgs indeed every
innovation would have
negative spillover effects on at least
one other sdg
predictably so one has to
think about the totality of impacts just
because we're trying to reduce hunger
or we're trying to improve soil
sustainability
we're trying to preserve fisheries we
have to pay attention to there will be
effects in other domains
hence the need for portfolio approaches
finally and this shouldn't be a hard
sell for this audience science is
fundamental to innovation
especially in evolutionary systems the
pest and pathogen pressures are changing
the the climate is changing all of that
means we need science
even just to adapt the things we already
do so together these four key features
of agri-food systems which we summarize
in the mnemonic is
you have to keep in mind that the
agri-food systems are his
that they are characterized by these
four attributes
but we must make them hers and that is
the next to the key conclusion so the
the group set about trying to define
what are our
visions for our objectives for the
agri-food systems
at a 50-year horizon so 50 years from
now in 2070
what would be the defining features of
food systems that we would celebrate
and we came up with these four key
features that were not
part of the defining vision of a food
system that
increases the pile of rice available for
food short consumers
which is all about productivity
efficiency and dietary energy
here it's about healthy diets it's about
a range of products
available healthy safe to consume
providing the full suite of nutrients as
well as non-nutritive
features of foods fiber for example
essential to good human health
second they will provide equitable
livelihoods where you don't have
disproportionate
catastrophic risk exposure to particular
people
who work dangerous jobs and are very
poorly paid
and commonly are indentured or inflated
third they'll be resilient systems
systems that can withstand pandemics
and climate change that can withstand
political turmoil etc
the changes in the world are
increasingly rapid
and consequential food systems
have been under significant stress in
the last year
many of us think they've performed
remarkably well but how many more times
can we subject them
to shocks of the sort we've just gone
through this last year
without them breaking and fourth and
perhaps
most compellingly to many panelists was
the need for sustainability the planet
just cannot grow
the food needed to to meet future
populations
with higher incomes without changing
methods of
food production back to farm and post
farm gate
so we articulated a vision of agri-food
systems as being hers in the future
and that future vision means that today
we need to shift away from yesterday's
objectives
but today we need to be looking forward
we need to look to what will be future
states not today's state so the third
key activity we did was defining the
external drivers what is going to change
between today
and 25 to 50 years from now not just to
the sdgs
because none of the bench science being
done in sips today
is going to have impact at scale in the
world by 2030. that's an unrealistic
timeline
agricultural r d's payoff at scale
occurs in the 10 to 30 year time window
disproportionately there are range of
studies
demonstrating this indeed publicly
funded r d begins to have its greatest
impacts starting at 15-year horizons and
beyond
not coincidentally public research pays
off beyond the traditional patent window
private research pays off in a nearer
term so if you're looking for
today's research that's going to impact
the world favorably
in realistic time horizons that's 25
years out
20 years out even 50 years out in some
cases
50 years ago we were talking about the
first
the first conference on rna we were
seeing the emergence
of the internet and email clients and
operating systems
that's 50 years ago 40 years ago so
we're talking about similar sorts of
horizons
the key three things we identified that
will define
the changes necessary in agri-food
systems between today
and that tomorrow first is climate
change for obvious reasons because so
much of it is baked in
and we've demonstrated such poor
commitment as a species
to shifting our behaviors to start
mitigating climate change
we simply have to be prepared to adapt
to it while still trying to mitigate
second population shifts basic
demography is
baked in populations that are going to
grow around the world
continuously in sub-saharan africa
through the rest of
this century they'll peak sometime
during the century and all other regions
of the world
indeed are already peaking in europe
probably this decade
but the population will not only grow
perhaps most importantly it's going to
urbanize and it's going to age
so that means that we are going to be
elongating supply chains
putting more demands on transportation
processing manufacturing
and distribution systems workforces
will be aging we'll have larger
populations of dependent
elderly people than we do today these
all matter to
how we design how we try to tweak food
systems
and income growth we should be desirous
of income growth in poor areas in
particular where people suffer
unnecessary poverty
but among poor populations as incomes
grow their demand for food products
grows very quickly much faster than it
does in the high income world
in economics this is called engel's law
that that the
the income elasticity of demand for food
as it's termed
is much higher uh for poorer populations
than it is for
for uh for richer populations the key
implication of
all of this really is that we must pay
far more attention to africa
where climate change is both going to be
quite pronounced but have its
some of its biggest impacts where
population shifts are going to be
greatest africa will be the most
populous region in the world
by the middle of the century and where
income growth will be
as fast as any other region of the world
but
will have a much bigger impact on the
food system because it starts from a
lower base
the implication ultimately is that more
than half
of demand growth for food around the
world
between now and 2100 will occur in
africa so we need to be designing we
need to be thinking about systems
that are prepared to absorb massive
changes in africa in particular
the final key point of the report before
i get to
the core essential actions was we went
through and we did an enumeration
exercise and we came up with
a huge number of promising scientific
advances that are at various stages of
deployment readiness from things that
are
still really on the lab bench to
advances that are already out in
farmer's fields and are being adapted in
various outer ecosystems around the
world
this spans entire range of food value
chains
from restaurant kitchens and individual
consumer
kitchens and dining rooms to farmers and
the input suppliers and everything in
between
and it varies across geographies the
problem is not
adequate ideas and adequate new
innovations
the problem is packaging them and
evaluating them and directing them
to where they can achieve the the
greatest impacts individually
and especially as bundles of of
synergistic
complementary inputs so we see that as a
system that requires
dialogue this is again human agency is
at the heart of this so we
we ultimately crafted this heuristic to
represent
a feedback system where innovation
drives people to put together different
pieces
into context-dependent socio-technical
innovation bundles
so bundles of different innovations i'll
give you an example in just a moment
that are appropriate to a context for
solving a particular problem that can be
implemented and scaled
and that feeds back into assessment of
progress
and re-innovation adaptation so that
innovation cycle
guides an awful lot of what our
recommendations are about
the seven essential actions we
ultimately came down to
the key one is that you have to think
about this as bundles
there are no magic bullets there are no
single technologies or single policies
that will fix the problems we face that
will meet the needs that loom ahead
so we must bundle for three reasons
the first is there are really big
synergies between different
interventions think
back to the progress made in the early
rice innovations
originating from erie and national
agricultural research and extension
systems
in south and southeast asia ira ir64 etc
those have had an amazing impact on the
race economy of the world
now think about golden rice which has
been around for 20 some years
golden rice is if anything just as
remarkable a scientific accomplishment
although i defer to those of you who are
breeders who can appreciate these issues
better than i can
but golden race is still not being
cultivated
in an open commercially available way
anywhere in the world
it is heavily regulated in the few
places that have it in the field
it's not diffused in more than 20 years
since it's
quite celebrated discovery why well
there are a whole host of reasons but
many of them are that there aren't the
supporting policy and institutional
infrastructure
ira and ir 64 were rolling out at a time
when
especially asian governments were
building rural roads they were working
on land tenure
they were providing extension they were
developing irrigation systems
they helped with nars that would help to
adapt
uh varieties to local contexts all of
these
other innovations complemented the basic
germplasm change
so those synergies are crucial
innovations
are they're supporting innovations that
are sort of like the backup singers
for for a good band second key reason
for socio-technical innovation bundles
is the need to address political economy
issues as i mentioned there is no
innovation we could identify
that we could not predict will have some
negative spillover effect
in some domain so how do you internalize
that
well you come up with some complementary
intervention that is intended to address
this adversely affected domain so for
example when we think about
uh when we think about germplasm it's
going to pull more nutrients from the
soil
to fill out larger panicles with higher
yields
then we need complementary interventions
to address the soil consequences of that
if you aren't replenishing nutrients
in the soil that are now winding up in a
greater harvest of grain
you're going to have a problem so what
are the complementary interventions to
ascend to the soil consequences of
increasing yields
so that is a rather trivial example that
you guys can appreciate more than others
can but at broader scale as we think
about things like
the rise of fermentation-based
substitutes for meats the
beyond and impossible and omni
substitutes
well these are pulling production of
food away from traditional farming
with consequences for livestock
producers for feed grain producers
for rural landowners and places that
depend upon feed grain and livestock
production
that has big political economy
consideration so it's no wonder
there's massive resistance to calling
some of these products
meat even cellular meat produced by
tissue engineering that is
as tissue identical to that taken from a
slaughtered animal
there's there's a great deal of
political resistance
to labeling that need why because you
are
threatening a particular constituency
how do you address that
you bundle things together you attend to
the needs of those constituencies
without bundling we invite political
opposition to progress that is necessary
and finally there are different needs
that there
are rarely individual innovations that
can attend to all the needs
one has so for example the challenge of
reducing micro
micronutrient deficiencies in
communities where many people don't get
enough vitamins or minerals
a problem i know many faculty and
students work on
you know this needs nutrition education
to improve dietary choice
it needs school feeding programs that
provide a more diverse
nutrient-rich diet those are our policy
innovations but those aren't going to
suffice
we know that because we try that in lots
of places and we often see
some positive but very incomplete and
ultimately unsatisfactory
results this also requires things like
industrial fortification
which is partly as a regulatory issue do
require
the particular products be fortified
with for example folic acid or
iron or do you require salt be iodized
partly this is bio-fortification
improvements in germ plasms so that they
make bio-available key minerals and
nutrients putting all of those pieces
together
like the puzzle piece is represented
here is an essential task of bundling of
innovations to attend to the challenges
that are going to vary by context so
hence lots of different
puzzle pieces put together in different
ways
second key essential action is the need
to reduce the land and water footprint
of food
we simply can't sustain basing all
production of food
on the land we're seeing that with the
encroachment in wild areas and zoonoses
as well as climate change
so transitioning more rural lands from
farming feed grains
or even farming livestock
to farming wind and solar energy and
carbon sequestration
and geothermal energy and habitat
conservation
and beginning to produce more of our
foods in vertical agriculture structures
like the one depicted here in india
or in in precision fermentation based
production of meat substitutes like this
picture from impossibles facilities
out in california that process of
de-agrarianization
of decoupling the production of food
from the land from the agrarian process
much like a century ago we began
decoupling the production of food from
labor
through the process of mechanization so
we have a very similar sort of
substitution
that is on the cusp of taking off now
just as a hundred years ago many people
had a hard time imagining
turning machines loose on the
countryside to produce most of our food
rather than than than men and women with
hoes and shovels and breaks today
it's hard to imagine lots of food not
being produced
it's hard to imagine lots of our food
being produced away from farms in
factories and urban and peri-urban areas
but that is where we're heading and we
have to manage the creative destruction
of that geography
the agrarianization process cleverly
we need to commit to doing this in
partnership so a lot of that is around
agreeing to an articulating key
performance measures
setting up safety nets so the people who
fall between the cracks during
transitions
aren't worried about that that they have
the assurance that collective progress
isn't going to have
individual casualties and penalizing
agreeing to penalties for those who
who break the social trust to engage in
activities that are
harmful to others so this is necessary
this is not easy
but this is necessary and we have some
examples of this proceeding so the
science and technology backyards
innovations
in in china are a particularly exciting
idea
and a very powerful example that some of
you are already aware of
so let me let me fast forward through
these in the interest of time
because rebecca's going to spend some
time talking about what are the
implications for sips
and for cornell more broadly but let me
just briefly
just flag deconcentrating power is going
to be a crucial issue here again
political
economy works in the background of most
of this we simply have too many people
who can
who can stall progress because they
stand to lose
we have to think more carefully about
systemic risk management
if covit has made no other impression
upon anybody
we hope that it is that there are big
and growing systemic risks out there
we must be prepared to manage including
in agri-food systems
we can mobilize tons of money we've just
appropriated in the united states 1.9
trillion dollars
earlier this month for covid relief
we can mobilize huge sums of money very
quickly and
investors around the world are looking
for new places to invest
there are these huge speculative bubbles
on sports cars and
baseball cards and and paintings because
lots of rich organizations and
individuals have no place to put money
where they think we'll earn a decent
return
they're increasingly looking to
innovations in things like agri-food
systems
we just need to mobilize private
resources to complement
what can be made available through
philanthropies and through public
spending that requires good measurement
because
private dollars follow measure
measurable performance metrics
part of this is reconfiguring public
support for agri-food systems
we have a farm bill that looms ahead in
the united states
this is a tremendous opportunity for us
to to try to redefine in the united
states and thereby
model for other countries the need to
put government
in the role of investing in essential
public goods and services
and facilitating dialogue to find
cooperative solutions
and less in in just wasteful
distortionary behavior
so much of the in the government
spending in the agri-food system today
is not especially productive it's not
investment in research and extension and
key infrastructure and social protection
it's payoff programs to political
friends
so with that let me pass over to rebecca
and end my
screen share because i know she's got
slides the website
available through the atkinson center
has all the products of the expert panel
including links to journal articles as
well as to the report and its summary
so i thank you all very much for your
time and interest let me turn it over to
rebecca there you go
hey thanks a lot so so thank you so much
chris
um and andy and just to recap quickly
where we've gotten so far so chris has
gone over some of the pressures on the
food system
some of the changes that are happening
as a result of those pressures such as
climate change demographic transitions
income
shifts what responses are needed to
mitigate
the inequalities and the food insecurity
and the environmental degradation that's
happening as a consequence
how do we get to that healthy equitable
resilient and sustainable food system we
want
differently in different places and how
and
so the real question that i'm kind of
wanting to get at is you know what do us
plant and animal scientists have to
offer so
i will not presume to actually try to
answer any of these questions
and uh you know i'm terrified to address
the last one so
what i'm gonna do is more think of
questions
that are pertinent to us as as sips
members
um and and invite your questions so i'll
i'll put mine out there i'm sort of
cherry-picking out the
bits that i found particularly
interesting and really helped us solicit
the conversation i think
i think we need to live these questions
we need to have these conversations i
look forward to hearing your thoughts
and
reactions um just to say that
chris mentioned this profuse pipeline of
promising possibilities
and we had a team of wonderful
undergraduate and graduate students who
was supporting that expert panel
along the way and they scoured the
literature before we even met
and come up with you know more than a
hundred innovations which is a
cornucopia of apples oranges pears um
car parts you know like um policies
institutional stuff
too so they were could categorize they
categorized those innovations as
agricological biochemical digital
mechanical
um cultural dietary policy and
institutional and then the panel
sort of got together and discussed them
as as
chris mentioned at roosevelt roosevelt
island we came up with a notionally
smaller list and did a quick little vote
and then we you know got to writing as
as some teams on those topics and then
the situation
took its own course um i guess i'm
partly showing this to
to give respect to hats off to the
student team
the incredible wealth of innovations
that are in progress
and in and consequently the poultryness
of the list that i will personally being
addressed addressing here
i did kind of um want to point out that
the number one voted topic was the
circular economy of organic materials
and i was i was both surprised and
delighted because that's one of the
things that really captivated my
imagination as well going through this
so at some point along the way i did a
quick mind map
of the innovations that the student team
had found out
and i just wanted to acknowledge that
one of the longer lists on that
on that area was was digital agriculture
and just to say i'm not going to say
more about that but to acknowledge that
cornell's got a very vibrant
um digital agriculture endeavor going on
and um i just wanted to also point out
that rick and gandhi
is an amazing person who was one of our
panel members who took the lead on this
particular
topic and if you're interested in
digital or you're not
you still might want to read what rickon
has put into that section and i just
wanted to note that he is giving a
seminar in the soylent crop science
seminar series in may so may 6 so i
i would um always recommend hearing him
um
at any opportunity but it's great that
he's coming up so he was a great
panelist to work with
i will be touching on this issue of
agroecology
um and so the question here might be
what would it take to shift
food production towards greater
sustainability
and probably this one ought to be this
is that circular economy for organic
materials
what would it take to turn organic waste
they're not wasted if we don't waste
them
into research resources instead of
pollutants
and really that you know properly ought
to be seen as a subset of agroecology
of course um chris has already mentioned
this idea of a radical change in protein
production
through fermentation and um
another of our panelists was ed buckler
our very own
um and we'd actually hope to get him as
a co-panelist for today's
presentation and since he wasn't
available i i
stole a few of his thoughts for this
presentation
which i will acknowledge as i go along
um so then the question is
if this big change is coming um fast and
soon
and hard what what does it have what are
the implications for us as plant
scientists and animal
and and how does it affect the
stakeholders for whom we do our work
okay so to the agricology topic
um this there's been a tremendous amount
written and said about this recently or
at least that's my strong impression
because mcknight foundation
um program that andy mentioned beginning
that i've worked for for a couple of
decades now has that as a central focus
and so i you know somewhat track the
increasingly large number of thought
pieces such as the
report that we put together that are
talking about the need to
put agriculture whether it's subsistence
uh smallholder farming or large-scale
industrial agriculture
on a more sustainable footing
and so one of the thoughts is sort of
relevant i mean related to
what chris said that we don't want to
just design pieces of the system and let
the chips fall and they may we actually
have to think of
entire systems i think we're we're
inclined and prone to
breeding for or managing components of
the system but you know
if we bring a systems view to it
you know we stand to improve the
performance of entire systems
through better soil biology nutrient
cycling um
performance against the many climate
induced
problems that slam our systems all the
time including the
rapidly evolving pest and disease
problems and we stand to contribute
towards
the healthy aspect of hers the healthy
and diverse diets that we increasingly
are aware that we need
um so when when the subject comes up
it's often well yeah
that works you know for smallholders
operating tiny pieces of land but
how do you mechanize that so what's the
what's the answer how do we recognize
that
i suppose we can mechanize it if we want
to how do we scale it i suppose we can
do it if we want to
so thinking of how the idea of
agriculture has evolved over time
um this is a a recent paper that
included uh
cornell co-author rachel doesn't occur
in global development
um so the the timeline here of
ecological thinking goes from the 1930s
um
into towards the present and of course
agriculture has been going on for all
time
but as a science it's sort of concerned
itself initially with plot and field
and it's been getting more ample in its
scope from farm to ecosystem
into the you know the ecology of the
entire food system
it's taking on principles that are
initially sort of more biophysical
agricultural
environmental and increasingly social
and cultural issues
economic and political issues so if i
think of okay so what's
what's the question that i would pose
here um
so you know as a person who works on
custom disease issues
um you know i i took this picture of a
farmer in the peruvian andes
he's spain spraying fungicides which are
not necessarily good for its
the compound or whatever it is is
dripping down his leg he's giving me
this nice thumbs up always spraying his
potato crop which he probably does every
every week or every three days to keep
it from being destroyed by potato lately
so i think we have long have recognized
that it's probably not a healthy thing
to
to hose down the planet with pesticides
or you know
potentially toxic compounds at regular
intervals but what would it take to
shift
from a global reliance on pesticides to
the use of agricultural principles i
think a lot of us in sips have been
working on
you know the science of you know disease
resistance or similar from for many
years
but the the scientific findings
themselves do not necessarily
change practice so it's increasingly
recognized that agroecology has
different spheres particularly science
practice and movement and i think to the
point chris made about
puzzle pieces we can see the need to fit
those puzzle pieces together
to achieve the outcomes that we think
are important
so um you know we can produce all the
science we want about disease resistance
about
multi-trophic interactions whatever it
is but to really change
practice what does it take we haven't
been that effective do we need
to team up with movement actors to
pressure for the policies that would for
example
disfavor pesticide use and support
agricultural principles and it's
it's been notable and unfortunate that
the movement actors have
preferred to focus on being an obstacle
to the use of transgenic or you know
gene modification
technologies and seem to give pesticide
use a lot more of a pass and i think
would be reasonable
so you know can we again work these
socio-technical bundles more effectively
can we get um can we help you know team
up with science practice and movement to
attain
the changes in the the agricultural
level of the food system that we
we know to be so important so moving on
to a second
sort of topic that i found intriguing
and compelling
um that's the idea of circular economy
so
this morning i was on one phone call
about agony ecology it was a funders
group
um talking about how you know what's the
spending on agricultural science
pregnancy movement from donor agencies
national bilateral um multilateral
and then earlier in the day i was on a
phone call
that was sponsored by the ellen
macarthur foundation on
circular economy in new york city again
there was an interesting
cornell team that was also part of that
conversation
who i had never met before anyway so the
idea is um
how i'll i'll say a little bit more
about that concept but the question here
that motivates me
is how can i how can we contribute to
developing what
um i might call the circular bionutrient
economy
so um just to i suppose people
are familiar with this concept but just
to review the idea of a linear economy
as one that
takes raw materials um in that might be
mined or
manufactured produce um produces stuff
with them
we use it and then we throw it away so
you know we don't
follow such an extreme view we have some
you know recycling and reuse in our
society but it's
we could go a lot farther to really
making sure that
we keep me mapped through recycling up
cycling
um repurposing we keep materials in in
use a lot longer until we get something
that might resemble this more circular
economy
so what would that mean when we think
about agriculture
and we think about plant science well
first off um
people used to i mean farming used to be
extremely circular
and we still have that heritage to draw
upon but throughout my lifetime
there's been this you know as chris
mentioned this fabulous revolution where
we
were able to benefit from the wonders of
the petrochem chemical
um fossil fuels and we figured out how
to manufacture nitrogen from
fossil fuel and we mined phosphorus the
use of those inputs as chris mentioned
has given us
tremendous success in just multiplying
each global cereal yields for example by
two to three fold
and it's that's going to come with a
bunch of goods but as chris mentioned
you know a bunch of
and as we all know a bunch of
environmental uh
problems pollution loss of soil or
organic matter you know
um eutrophication harmful algal blooms
and so on
because of the fact that a lot of those
fertilizers that we're putting on the
land and that run through our bodies are
coming out into our bodies of water
leading to this kind of mess that we
have
so and just an example is that more than
half the energy that goes into
taking a corn kernel and turning into a
corn ear is comes from the nitrogenous
fertilizer
again that we make through the huber
bosch process which is based on
you know fossil fuel use so
how do we circularize well i mean we can
look at all of the different
organic organic waste that we have they
could be industrial they could be
yard waste kitchen market including
human excretis or
waste before and after consumption and
the traditional recycler is the pagan
for example in chinese
traditional agriculture and one thing i
learned that i really enjoyed from this
panel
work was that the black soldier fly is
the new you know
micro livestock the new um or mini
livestock
the new pig it'll take really you know
market waste human waste
um and turn it into very high quality
protein and fat which
is really considered to be essential for
now making a sustainable fishery
industry
now like a large a fraction of the the
ocean catch is fed to farm salmon
and we can use the uh we uses biochar
we can produce fish feed you know
poultry feed
food and then return that again um
in a circular manner so that's sort of
looking on the micro scale
at the macro scale how do we return that
um
how do we deal with this disequilibrium
and nutrients is piling up in urban
areas where all the people are
the foods coming to the city and piling
up as pollution going into our water
bodies
how do we bring that back onto the land
that's another whole question that we
can
uh tackle and work on and that um you
know i'm feeling it excited to work on
myself with with colleagues incepts
and elsewhere so you know to take such a
thing forward particularly the
ecological sanitation
um close the loop and transform the poop
you know we face a huge amount of
perception challenges there are
technical issues
there are um obstacles in terms of you
know sunk costs and sewers and then
the way that we currently handle matters
so there's just enormous challenges of
all
sorts that are questions that we can
live and take up and challenge over time
again a tremendous need to do these
socio
socio-technical bundling to accomplish
actual change on the ground
um coming to the third topic here i
notice we're running short on time
i want to come back to the topic that
chris raised this intriguing issue of
de-agrarianization now i think all of us
in sips are
pro-agrarianization and yet we recognize
that whether we like it or not there it
will increasingly be this decoupling of
food production
and land and to some extent it's a great
thing um chris showed this you know
veggie production in india
such things also this is the middle of
los angeles super high tech
controlled environment agriculture but
it can also be
low tech you know rooftop school garden
this is a company an ipm a pest
management company
that's growing for its employee it's a
tremendous amount of food on a roadside
basis so it's a
small enterprise growing huge amount of
really healthy fruit and veg on that
roadside of a perry urban street and so
how much food will we be able to produce
um you know this is an important
question would be using some of those
wastes that are now
causing urban environments to be fairly
disgusting
on wholesome areas how much can we we
recycle those wastes and turn them into
healthy foods for people um that
also can contribute to livelihoods as as
well as hygiene and well-being
and i think the most um radical
idea that i encountered um from the
experience thinking of
of sociotechnical bundles that are
relevant to our
area was this one that that chris
mentioned about
microbial fermentation to produce
protein
so this is an idea that ed buckler's
given a lot of deep thinking too and he
gave a really great
plant breeding seminar recently so if
you weren't able to see that and you're
taking interest in that you might
like see his unpacking of the issues um
on a recorded
plant breeding seminar but the idea is
the rationale is simple fermentation is
just more efficient
microbes are pretty damn efficient they
make great protein they do it really
fast
so you've got all meat that's based on
plants on cell culture but now
could you know in completely you know
separated from land entirely
we've been manufacturing really
inexpensive meat and just to say that
there's a lot of stuff in the discussion
of the panel also about alternative
feeds
using seaweeds new crops like camelina
black soldier flies
other ways that we can um you know in
fact bolster the livestock industry so
i don't think the message should be too
simplistic that we're out
there are or um a lot of money going out
against the live respect industry but
there's you know a lot of things going
for it as well
but just to look at this uh rethink x
graph
showing um the price of beef
over time per kilo over these years and
you can see that
they're projecting that fermented
protein is going to be just much cheaper
than you know cow beef really fast
um with and the cell-based protein is
going to come along much more slowly so
you know we might be looking at a
radical shift
in what we're eating just based on the
price because of this so i don't know if
you buy that or not be interested to
hear your opinions
but in any case it's going to have
implications beyond you know the meat
industry
so this is just a figure showing what we
do with corn
every dot here is 25 million bushels
there of
and you know we eat a teeny bit of it um
we
use a little bit for these different
food items we
we export some of it we burn quite a bit
of it and we feed a
huge fraction of it to animals so if
those animals are going to become much
fewer
you know that's going to have enormous
implications for crop production as well
so
um just to wrap up um so plant science
you know has a tremendous amount to to
contribute and i'd love to hear
more thoughts if there's a few minutes
for discussion um
you know how can we contribute
specifically i've i've mentioned
a couple of things i didn't really
mention diversification and
and uh carbon's orchestration as much as
i could but so
um per per the observations of chris
made we need to be working together with
the other stakeholders
to make or turn our science into actual
change
to create a new and better future um
that we can have
that viewing this report gave me a lot
of hope and inspiration for how we can
do better
i want to say i really appreciate
working with all the panelists and hats
off to my amazing
chair chris barrett who's a force of
nature and
um always a thrill and delight to work
with but i would love to work
you know think more with my fellow
members of steps too about how can we
contribute
what do we have to do to make these
contributions
real um over
thanks a lot rebecca and chris that was
that was wonderful
there's a monitoring the chat here
we're a little bit over time but if you
guys would permit a couple of questions
i'm sure the floor has
has a few things to ask you someone has
there and
marvin please go ahead yeah did the
group consider
anything about the effect of plants on
human well-being beyond
food think about green space and you
know their ability
to be involved in that recycling process
flowers things like that that we work on
in plants but it's not
something that we directly consume
great points marvin um at a first order
approximation no
um so there's a little bit of passing
discussion of
the value of green spaces and of active
participation in
food systems people just get enjoyment
out of this
but the focus of the group was very much
on satisfying global food needs
without thinking about other human needs
or other other gains
so excellent point although i would also
say
marlon when i think about that issue of
urban and perry urban food production
sort of
d d agrarianized in the sense that you
know you might be growing stuff not
you know on the land that you own as a
farm
for me a really important point is the
idea of beautification
of the you know the idea of giving
people that um
the beauty of plants so for me when i
think about my like strawberry gardening
you know schemes
um and sac based gardening it's it's in
part trying to think of how can we make
this beautiful how can we make it
appealing
to give people that psychic relief that
i think they really need in those
in those blank difficult environments so
thank you for that point
i think the panel is very sympathetic to
your point but it doesn't feature
prominently in the report
hi a great presentation i enjoyed it
what insights can you share with us
about this on agrarian farming this
vertical farming
it is it in fact is it promising for its
impact on the environment
and its uh use of uh you know limited
resources is is the
ecology of that highly favorable in
comparison to the agrarian systems right
now
um so great question gary like
absolutely every other innovation we
talked about
there will be negative effects from it
right now that i i hope that's one of
the key takeaways people
took from the work that we did in this
report there there
are no solutions that generate only
gains in some dimension and nothing
bad in another dimension so you need
offsetting things in the case of
vertical
uh farming you know it's it's remarkable
how fast it's changing
this is now a profitable venture in
asian cities
i mean there are a bunch of companies
many of them from cornell alums as it
turns out
who've got startups that have
turned a profit within a couple of years
and are providing high quality greens
and berries to urban and perry urban
consumers and not just
you know the elite not just rich people
paying a premium
a lot of this is improvements in solar
energy production
that the price point on panels has come
down
fast uh improvements in uh in
indoor water distribution and heat
regulation
so a lot of the adverse energy
effects that have long been associated
with vertical farming are coming down
quickly but you know it's
it's obviously more energy consuming to
not use the sun directly
so there's it will always be more
efficient in terms of how we convert
solar energy
into calories and plants if the sun
directly grows the plant rather than you
have to intermediate
so there is clearly a loss there the
question
is can you compensate for that with
gains in other places where you can then
wind up generating an aggregate gain
including better energy use
and reducing carbon footprints despite
less efficient energies thank you
thank you gary thank you chris uh
christina you're next
um thank you for presenting this work um
so
it's great to hear the examples that you
mentioned of
um you know startups that are using
scientific knowledge and creating
things that are beneficial you also
mentioned how
some people have way too much money and
they're doing things like buying you
know
100 million dollar electronic images um
so given that you know there are a lot
of people with money
uh who have no ability to distinguish
between what makes sense and what
doesn't
um what measures do you know do we need
in place
and what can we do so that um you know
people with absurd amount of money
aren't defining what the best path
forward is and aren't you know sort of
creating
so-called solutions that don't actually
respect
what people need or you know also don't
sort of aren't supported by the science
um yeah so i i feel like you and i agree
on this
in a fairly deep level the i guess the
reason i throw that example
out is it is so absurd and your example
of electronic images is an even better
one than
baseball cards um what's what's the
intrinsic value of these things it's got
to be trivially small
so people are just engaged in sort of
hobbies
here but in many cases they really are
trying to make money
um and they're they're trying to make
those that are trying to make money i
don't
i don't claim all are they we should
interpret this as they are starved for
places where they can invest their money
where they think there will be
gains and they can measure them and
capture them
and this is part of where some of the
advances
in digital technologies offer so much
promise
because we know for example that
consumers are prepared to pay
for lots of attributes of foods
sustainability attributes health
attributes
even social justice attributes if they
have confidence
that they're not just you know subject
to marketing gimmicks
if you can verify attributes of food
as we begin to develop the ability to
cost effectively demonstrate was there
really deforestation
in the area from which this palm oil
originated that's in this product
people are willing to pay a premium for
that right now you pay for certifiers
and the cost of of certification
in most cases exceeds the premium
consumers are willing to pay
in some ways this is like the the
problem of
solar power which for years was a great
idea but way too expensive to implement
at scale
as digital technologies are making it
increasingly feasible to come up with
really
low-cost credible verification of
producer claims about products
and their origins we're at the cusp of
unlocking
some of the ability to mobilize the
funding
that we that many of us are willing to
put into paying a little bit of a
premium for our products
and they're i mean that market is big
there are investors ready to go into
this heavily
but right now it's not measurable um so
we're probably not far away from that
but
you know investors are really quant
oriented people they
they need to be able to see how what
will trigger pay off
uh when we get there i think we'll stop
seeing quite so much frivolous
investment
and a little bit more mobilization of
funding for some things that i think a
lot of this
the community on today's call cares
about thank you christina and chris
uh mamadou you're next
hello everybody thank you chris for the
presentation rebecca good to see you
chris thank you for connecting with
those along who are doing a great job in
india
appreciate emilia um i guess i'm gonna
just take up on
what you just mentioned now like one of
the limitations
it's really funding uh we know the big
part of
this system for this innovation to work
is not really the electronics
all those are cheaper now it's mostly
the solar as you mentioned
several years ago it's been there and
it's been made
it's been there for long it's still not
affordable of course it has really the
price of solar has decreased
tremendously over the last 10 years i
guess i'm trying to do a parallel
between what happened in the last 20
years
1999 to today about 20 22 years ago
we're talking about livestock revolution
it was a big talk
we're just saying and that was driven by
what by income
by middle income increasing in the world
and we're more concerned about the
environmental impact of that now we're
talking about great
innovation great uh inventions
and what actually to me and of course
this is very early to say
to me is something that actually will be
helping
into leaving some lands able to generate
will be actually having more positive
impact
on the environment agroecology as
rebecca mentioned and all that
but still this thing i'm wondering for
is it going to take 20 years again for
funding to be available
what do you think are the limitations
for this to go fast because there's
really because i'm working on it already
there is tremendous opportunity
not only for people who are trying to
make money
but people who are trying to just make
more food and income available for those
who cannot afford it and access to
better food
right there in middle of cities right
there in
doesn't require much of land what will
be
how to make funding go faster
yeah so the um the section in the report
on innovative financing which i would
encourage you to go
check out was um
an important contributor to that text
was another cornell alumnus andrew moody
a kenyan
who's now at the african development
bank where a big part of his
responsibilities at the african
development banker
are mobilizing private capital for
investment in
africa's agri-food sectors so everything
from
input suppliers you know folks like the
hello tractor and other cornellian
startup
you know those sorts of ventures that
just need startup capital
to downstream processors and restaurants
and
co-ops community supported agriculture
movements that are trying to get
onto digital platforms so that people
can subscribe much more easily
all of these sorts of ventures fall
within andrew's remit and he's involved
in a lot of really exciting discussions
there is a lot of capital flashing
around there
but it's hard this is a as
as much as many of us like to make fun
of bankers
and how horrible they can be in their
stereotypes
they play an important role and if they
can help
find the the money that is going after
frivolous investments you know that's
buying digital images
that could better spend five million
dollars investing in your startup
working in the sahel mamadou
uh you know that's the role that andrew
and
others like him are trying to play right
now so i would encourage you read the
innovative financing instrument section
of the report
and follow up with somebody like andrew
who's really doing it day to day
yes because what i will do
thank you great uh i
we can leave the channel open but i
think we ought to close the meeting now
since we're 15 minutes over
and uh chris rebecca thank you so much
that delight having you both here was
really
very thought provoking excellent
presentations thank you so much
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu